[Music]
i'm a friend of sierra connor i was told
that she's here could i see her please
no can't see her she's making a
statement
where is she
look it may take a while you want to
wait there's a bench over there
i'll be back
hey there it's mark ellis and welcome to
a new exclusive episode of rt essentials
and when i say exclusive i'm talking
about a club where only the freshest of
the fresh the greatest of the goats are
welcome there's no membership you can
buy and your tick tock stats hold no
sway in this domain oh you're a
socialite so what your benjamins mean
nothing your cousin's jlo
that's pretty awesome but still not
gonna get you into this club and don't
even try to bribe that bouncer because
this is the rotten tomatoes 100 club and
if you want to be on this list you need
to make cinematic gold a film with a
flawless critical reception no rotten
marks all fresh reviews and at least 40
of those seems like an impossible task
to get to a hundred percent considering
the fragile factors that can make or
break a movie one flat performance one
cheesy line of dialogue one shoddy cgi
rendering and critics are going to
pounce like literary lines ripping your
work to shreds
so with that in mind let's give some of
these tenacious titles a closer look
terminator
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
starting with james cameron's
breakthrough feature the terminator
released in october of 1984. the film
stars linda hamilton in the pivotal role
of sarah connor michael bean is the time
traveling soldier kyle reese and of
course as the terminator the guy who i
just did a horrible impression of arnold
schwarzenegger now in case you're
unfamiliar with terminators they're a
series of cyborg assassins with human
features and thick accents for some
reason created by the evil intelligence
network skynet in the first terminator
schwarzenegger is cyberdyne systems
model 101 aka a t-800 and travels back
in time to kill sarah connor connor is
bewildered by this assault but soon
learns that her unborn son john connor
will grow up to lead the revolution
against skynet and their army of
machines hence the target on her back
the concept was lofty even for cameron
who at the time only had one director
credit to his name needless to say there
is plenty of room for air especially
since the film was pitched as a
post-apocalyptic sci-fi horror slasher
cameron also admitted that the idea for
the terminator came to him during a
fever dream in which he envisioned a
chrome skeleton holding kitchen knives
and emerging from a fire you know most
people dream about teeth falling out or
being naked in public not you jim of
course most of the director's colleagues
including his agent thought this idea
was crazy and the camera should focus
his attention elsewhere but as we all
know james cameron is not easily
deterred like most of his films the
terminator proved to be a monumental
success and not just commercially though
it did gross over 78 million dollars
against a budget of just six mil the
film submitted schwarzenegger's leading
man persona in hollywood and skyrocketed
james cameron's career as a writer
director the la times called the film a
crackling thriller full of all sorts of
gory treats and the guardian wrote that
getting the extraordinary physical
specimen of arnold schwarzenegger for
the lead role was the stroke of genius
the film spawned a successful franchise
consisting of six movies some of which
are okay a television series and was
selected for preservation in the
national film registry by the library of
congress
nice nightfall walk
wash day tomorrow
nothing clean right
nothing clean right hey i think this
guy's a couple can short of a six-pack
you're close
give them to me now let's not forget the
most notable achievement of the
terminator a spot in our 100 club toy
story one and two right now poised at
the edge of the galaxy emperor zerg has
been secretly building a weapon with a
destructive capacity to annihilate an
entire planet i alone have information
that reveals this weapon's only weakness
you are a toy
you weren't the real buzz lightyear
you're now you're an action figure over
25 years ago toy story became the first
entirely computer animated feature and
put pixar animation studios on the map
the film is set in a world where toys
come to life and follow his cowboy doll
woody chucky spaceman action figure buzz
lightyear online about one of those and
an ensemble of fun-sized counterparts on
a quest to reunite with their owner andy
tom hanks voices woody tim allen is buzz
and don rickles plays a clumsy mr potato
head there's also a slinky dashan a
nervous t-rex a wise piggy bank and a
porcelain little bo peep who is woody's
love interest toy story's journey began
as a short film called tin toy created
by director john lasseter lassner
pitched the concept to steve jobs who
owned pixar and jobs agreed to finance
the project at the time the future of
pixar was uncertain so this investment
was seen as risky but jobs being the
visionary he was saw the potential in
what laster had created and of course he
was not wrong tin toy went on to win the
academy award for best animated short
film the first fully cgi flick to ever
win at the oscars and this captured the
attention of disney soon tom hanks and
tim allen were signed on to star in a
feature inspired by tin toy with pixar
and disney joining forces toy story set
the tone for all pixar films that
followed expertly blending humor with
emotional depth and doing so in a way
that was entertaining for all ages it's
no easy feat to create movies that
parents and their children can equally
get excited about but pixar seems to
have this formula down to a science and
has proven their ingenuity time and time
again critics unanimously praised toy
story with many considering it a
masterpiece and one of the greatest if
not the greatest animated films of all
time additionally the film was nominated
for two golden globes and three oscars
and earned lassiter a special
achievement academy awards
four years later pixar released the
sequel toy story 2 which rivaled its
predecessor in critical reception and
surpassed it in box office crows both
films have rightfully earned their place
in the 100 club although toy story 3
fell off a cliff and is what 98 is still
really really good
singing in the rain
tito
[Music]
no no miss lamont round tones round
tones singing in the rain was released
in 1952 in stars gene kelly debbie
reynolds donald o'connor and gene hagen
kelly plays don lockwood a silent film
star making his debut in the world of
the talking pictures don falls for
chorus girl kathy selden played by
reynolds after she is brought in to
overdub his co-star lina's singing and
speaking by the end of the film kathy
becomes the real star when don
intentionally reveals her hidden talents
to a live audience kelly and reynolds
have a once in a century kind of
chemistry and their character romance
makes you want to well you know sing and
dance in the rain and risk getting
arrested and aside from that titular
track the film is loaded with singable
gems such as good morning moses supposes
and make them laugh the songs are
impeccably weaved through the narrative
cleverly dancing around the dialogue and
captivating even the most anti-musical
viewers you know the ones that are
always complaining that this genre is
unrealistic and people don't just break
into song and dance uh unrealistic did
you hear the synopsis for the terminator
actually that's a bad example because
that premise seems to be more realistic
with every day that passes anyways
critics weren't hesitant in sharing
their adoration of this classic the
guardian wrote that the unstoppable joy
of the musical numbers especially with
o'connor is what never fails to seduce
and the new york times said that all
elements in this rainbow program are
carefully contrived and guaranteed to
lift the dollars of winter and put you
in a buttercup mood that is a 100 fresh
review ladies gentlemen stop that girl
that girl running up the aisle stop her
that's the girl whose voice you heard
and love tonight she's the real star of
the picture and that's just it singing
in the rain is precisely what the title
suggests a source of melodious glee that
can brighten even the dampest of days
and with a much deserved spot in the 100
club this song still sings 70 years
later 7 samurai
japanese filmmaker akira kurosawa wrote
and directed seven samurai released in
1954 and starring tashira mafune takashi
shimira and kiko tsushima amongst many
others it tells the story of a team of
samurai assembled with the purpose of
protecting a small village from bandits
the film is set in 1586 during the
sengoku period of japanese history a
notoriously difficult and violent era
what makes this film so epic aside from
the 3 hour and 27 minute running time is
kurosawa's use of martial arts
choreography his multi-camera action
sequences and an inspired score by
composer fumio hayasaka it was also the
most expensive film ever made in japan
at the time and became the country's
second highest grossing domestic release
but the true spirit of kurosawa's work
is present in seven samurai remix like
the magnificent seven and ensemble
movies like the dirty dozen the guns of
navarone and more recently the hateful
eight and since kurosawa created the
film yojimbo which sergio leon
unofficially remade as a fistful of
dollars three years later kurosawa
should be credited for inventing the
spaghetti western genre in addition to
leon seven samurai had a profound
influence on directors like quentin
tarantino george lucas peter jackson and
the wachowskis those are some of the
heaviest hitters in hollywood history so
much thanks oh to kurosawa for the
blockbuster movies we know and love
today
wow
roger ebert would add seven samurai to
his coveted list of great movies it was
ranked number three on the guardians
poll of the 40 greatest foreign films of
all time and timeout magazine which i'm
told is not time magazine voted the
second best action film ever welcome to
the club seven samurai
rebecca
no stop
what the level you're shouting about
[Music]
who are you
what are you staring at
i'm sorry i didn't mean to stare but i i
only thought oh you did it too well what
are you doing here
i was only walking
well get on with your walking don't hang
about here screaming what would a list
of silver screen perfection be without
some hitchcock specifically 1940s
rebecca the director's first american
project the film is based on the daphne
de maurier novel of the same name and
features performances by lawrence
olivier and joan fontaine it also earned
producer david o selznick his second
best picture oscar in a row after
winning for gone with the win the
previous year kind of hard to believe
but this is the only hitchcock film ever
to take home a best picture oscar
despite several of his films being
nominated in that category and when
psycho is nominated you should have seen
the dress that mrs bates wore rebecca is
the story of a young woman who marries a
mysterious widower named max dewinter
and soon finds herself living in the
shadow of his former wife who
suspiciously died years earlier it
sounds like your average hitchcockian
tale so what sets this film apart from
any other work by the master of suspense
well the guardian called it one of
hitchcock's creepiest most oppressive
films which is really saying something
other critics wrote that it's subtle
electrifying and almost as fascinating
as the novel and that hitchcock
succeeded brilliantly in his initial
hollywood venture adding that he has
retold in his own creepy colorful way mr
marie's forbidding fascinating story of
life and death malignancy and murder in
2018 rebecca was selected for
preservation in the united states
national film registry by the library of
congress citing its cultural historical
and aesthetic significance
[Music]
are you all right
this is dangerous she's gone mad she
said she'd rather destroy mandolin and
see us happy here but we all know
hitchcock would have been most proud of
being in the 100 club good evening
indeed pinocchio father
what you're crying for because
you're dead pinocchio no
no i'm not yes
yes you are
now lie down but father i'm alive see
and i'm
i'm
i'm real
i'm a real boy that same year disney
released their second animated feature
pinocchio about a puppet whose nose
grows when well you know the story
there's a wood carver named geppetto
there's a magical blue fairy there's a
cricket who always has good advice to
give and he's wearing a top hat these
characters are so deeply ingrained in
our culture it's nearly impossible to
imagine a world in which they don't
exist what most people forget is that
pinocchio is based on an italian
children's novel by carlo colody
entitled the adventures of pinocchio
during the production of snow white and
the seven dwarfs animator norman
ferguson brought a translated copy of
the novel to walt disney who after
reading immediately commissioned bianca
majoli to write an adapted outline fun
facts majuli was the first woman to
become a storyboard artist for walt
disney productions and ferguson invented
the character pluto who is a good boy
walt disney trusting his team's idea to
adapt the adventures of pinocchio is
akin to steve jobs and tin toy both men
were visionaries that saw the potential
in a concept and weren't afraid to roll
the dice and as the saying and matt
damon selling crypto goes fortune
favored the bold pinocchio became the
first animated feature to win an academy
award taking home two one for best
original score and one for best original
song when you wish upon a star and
critics have called it emotionally
resonant with animation that is nothing
short of masterful
[Music]
me too father
[Music]
over 80 years later these characters and
themes continue to inspire welcome to
the club pinocchio 12 angry men say
something
you lousy bunch of bleeding hearts
you're not gonna intimidate me i'm
entitled to my opinion legendary
filmmaker sydney lumet directed 12 angry
men a courtroom drama released in 1957.
it was written by reginald rose and
produced by henry fonda who also starred
along with lee cobb ed begley e.g
marshall and jack warden the film
follows the closing arguments in a
murder trial where the fate of one inner
city teenager rests in the hands of the
12-member jury a guilty verdict means
the death penalty and much conflict
unfolds in the jury's deliberation hence
the movie's title the film was
originally produced as a television play
and after a successful run on the
program studio one rose adapted to
teleplay for the big screen the story's
inspiration came from rose's real life
experience as a jury member on a
manslaughter case according to rose
there was a terrific furious eight-hour
argument in the jury room and he
instantly realized this was the perfect
setting for a drama once the screenplay
was complete lumet was recruited and
this became his first feature film as a
director aside from rose's clever
writing and lamech sharp direction henry
fonda's performance as juror 8 is
considered by many to be his career best
although the jury's still out on that
one considering fonda has 11 films rated
100 percent that's got to be a record
right twelve angry men was revolutionary
for exploring issues of race and social
class and how those issues influenced
the justice system the film also ignited
the courtroom procedural craze that
still sweeps the screen today seen in
movies like the trial to chicago 7 and
shows like juan order bum bum the los
angeles times called 12 angry men a tour
de force in movie making the new york
times wrote that it makes for a taut
absorbing and compelling drama that
reaches far beyond the close confines of
its jury room setting secret what do you
mean secret there are no secrets in a
jewelry room i know who it was
brother you really are something you sit
here vote guilty like the rest of us and
some golden voice preachers starts
tearing your poor heart out about some
underprivileged kid just couldn't help
becoming a murderer and you change your
vote
if that isn't the most sick why don't
you drop a quarter in this collection
box and timeout wrote that lumet's
window into strained civic duty will
continue to serve mightily and that's
the whole truth your honor cool hand
luke what we've got here is
failure to communicate
some man
you just can't reach
so you get what we had here last week
which is the way he wants it
well he gets it cool hand luke was
released in october of 1967 and is based
on don pierce's novel of the same name
paul newman plays luke jackson a petty
criminal who gets a two-year sentence in
a florida prison and refuses to conform
to the shady antics of the warden or to
the established pecking order amongst
the inmates luke's behaviors lead him
into some painful situations such as
solitary confinement and imbalanced fist
fights and his numerous attempts to
escape only serve to escalate his
suffering but luke doesn't stay down and
soon he earns the respect of the other
prisoners and takes on the role of a
system-fighting martyr newman's
performance is one for the ages one that
no other actor could have pulled off
with such charisma and physical
determination interestingly enough
newman almost didn't get the part as
jack lemmon was originally selected to
portray luke but after lemon read the
script he believed that newman would be
a better fit so he passed and chose to
be a producer on the film instead this
might be the only live action movie on
our list where the director's talents
are overlooked though stuart rosenberg
had plenty of success and frequently
collaborated with newman many felt that
his direction on this film didn't cut it
the chicago reader even called
rosenberg's work a horror
yikes maybe the guy just had a failure
to communicate even with that cool han
luke received a near flawless critical
reception i'm gonna eat 50 eggs
nobody can eat 58. you just said he
could eat anything w58
nobody ever eat 50 eggs hey my blue guts
we got a bet here
my boy says he can eat 50 eggs he can
eat 50 eggs yeah man how long
that hour the film also earned four
oscar nominations grossed over 16
million dollars on a three million
dollar budget and forever cemented
newman as a cultural icon man on wire
what i do is under the copy of sneeze ah
i see the page put it under my jacket
and go out now of course i would have a
toothache for a week but what's the pain
in comparison that now i have acquired
my dream
man on wire is a biographical
documentary that chronicles daredevil
philly petit's high wire walk across the
world trade center buildings in 1974
director james marsh blends actual
footage with reenactments and uses
present day interviews to gain further
insight into the infamous stunt the film
is based on petite's 2002 book the
recounts his experience and the title
refers to the words written on the
police report that led to his arrest
petite is one of those characters that
seems too bizarre to be real one that
even the most astute of screenwriters
couldn't possibly have created he oozes
with personality superhuman skill and
speaks with such an eloquence and charm
rivaled only by that of your host today
not really he has this unwavering
passion for high wire walking it
consumes him and we the audience can't
help but be inspired by his conviction
not so much inspire that we're going to
walk across a rope that's staying with
1300 feet in the air but it gets you
amped up it's no wonder that joseph
gordon-levitt chose to portray petite in
the 2015 film the walk which is robert
domecca's dramatic take on the same
event man on wire took home the oscar
for best documentary feature at the 81st
academy awards and additionally won
sundance's grand jury prize for the
world cinema documentary grabbed me and
grounded me handcuffed actually hands in
the back i was thrown down the staircase
the most dangerous part of this whole
adventure i almost break my head on the
narrow staircase that lead to the
elevator the washington post wrote to
the film is an absorbing mischievously
amusing yarn whose climax unfolds with
unexpected emotional force and other
critics called it exhilarating and palm
poisoning leave no trace so what are you
doing here
i wasn't where i was supposed to be so
they took me away
oh
they don't think i was where i was
supposed to be last up is writer
director deborah granick's 2018 feature
leave no trace which premiered at
sundance and was distributed by bleeker
street media ben foster and rising star
and mackenzie brilliantly portray will
and tom a father and daughter living on
a nature reserve outside of portland
oregon the film is based on the true
story told in peter rock's novel my
abandonment published in 2009 and the
title refers to the leave no trace set
of ethics that began in the 1960s and is
used to promote conservation in the
outdoors granic explores socio-economic
environmental and mental health issues
in a way that is subtle yet impactful
and worthy of much praise the los
angeles times called leave no trace
fiercely evolving in a way we're not
used to made with sensitivity and
honesty and the guardian called it a
deeply intelligent story of love and
survival in the wild
so you don't need to be scared
additionally the film is nominated for
three satellite awards and two gotham
awards there you have it our selections
from the rotten tomatoes 100 club as
always we couldn't include every title
on that magnificent list but there's
plenty more rt essentials episodes
coming your way so stick around we'll
get there soon enough thanks for tuning
in i'm mark ellis i'll be back and to
all you aspiring filmmakers out there
who hope to one day find your way into
the 100 club remember these four words
to infinity and beyond
[Music]
[Music]